thanks to squarespace for helping
support this episode
go to squarespace.com science asylum and
add code science asylum at checkout
to save 10 off your first purchase hey
crazies
there's a whole list of ways the world
could end human-caused global warming
being the most immediate
but let's say we get over our
differences and we stop
unsustainably consuming resources we'll
still need to contend with the sun
eventually in about four or five billion
years
the sun will expand into a red giant
which
you know seems pretty dangerous so will
the earth survive
maybe maybe not
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
does the sun even have the power to
destroy the earth
oh oh yeah it's a giant ball of plasma
you might even say it's a miasma of
incandescent plasma
the sun isn't just big though it's also
massive
it has over 333 000 times the mass of
the earth
the sun represents 99.8
of the mass of the entire solar system
if you imagine the total mass of the
solar system as a thousand dollars
the sun is 998 of those dollars
about one of those two remaining dollars
goes to jupiter
leaving only one dollar for everything
else
given that it seems pretty clear the sun
does have the ability to destroy us
but will it to answer that we need to
understand how the sun
actually works let's start at the
beginning
no no no no stop that why do i keep
walking into that joke
anyway our entire solar system started
as a giant cloud of gas and dust
as it collapsed under gravity lumps
started to form in the cloud
some of the lumps became planets but
most of the mass of that cloud went into
a
central lump that would become the sun
remember
998 out of a thousand dollars
but it's not quite a star yet as the
matter in that central lump compresses
on itself
it heats up that high temperature does
allow the gas to emit light
but the outward pressure that light
exerts is nowhere near enough to hold
back gravity
this big lump of gas and dust continues
to collapse and continues to heat up
eventually it reaches a critical
temperature and bam
nuclear fusion ignites in the core the
sun is born
pure thermodynamics might not be enough
to hold back gravity
but fusion certainly can there's now
enough outward pressure to stop
the sun from collapsing the sun is
stable
it's in what we call hydrostatic
equilibrium
because it's a balanced fluid
it's not exactly static but just go with
it okay
there are two ways hydrogen can fuse the
proton proton chain
and the cno cycle which way does the sun
do it
both ways actually both types of
hydrogen fusion happen
simultaneously but not equally how much
of each type a star has
depends on core temperature right now
the sun is mostly fusing with the proton
proton chain
at a temperature of 15 million kelvin
but that won't be true forever the the
temperature of the sun
is gradually increasing when the solar
system was young
the sun was dimmer and cooler as fusion
uses up hydrogen
gravity pushes inward and the core heats
up more and more
this changes the proportions of the two
types of fusion
it also maintains equilibrium but at a
cost
that higher temperature makes fusion go
faster
fast fast over time the sun gets hotter
and brighter
about a billion years from now it'll be
so hot our oceans will boil away
the earth will become a desert planet
so does that mean there's no more humans
no more humans
on earth let's be optimistic here
a billion years is a long time assuming
we survive our own stupidity
i'm sure that we'll have at least
colonized the rest of the solar system
by then
there should be some places farther out
that are hospitable to humans
actually now that i'm thinking about it
we'll probably have evolved into
something else by then
yeah i i take it back no more humans
okay
so is that the end of the video nope the
earth still exists
it might be a lifeless desert but it
still exists
the sun still has one more chance to
destroy the earth
the red giant phase regardless of the
hydrogen fusion
process the goal is the same turn four
hydrogens
into one helium ton of times over and
over again
for as long as possible which
unfortunately
is not forever yes the sun has a lot of
hydrogen but it's still a finite amount
and only some of it is in the core
there's hydrogen in all the layers of
the sun but the core
only has about 12 percent of it that
means only 12
is available for fusion it's going to
run out of that eventually
and when it does hydrostatic equilibrium
cannot be maintained
near the end of its life the sun will
have spent 9 or 10
billion years fusing hydrogen into
helium
the core will be full of helium so it'll
be on its last leg
as a main sequence star as it uses up
the last of its core hydrogen
the outward pressure will drop and the
core will collapse
wouldn't the entire sun collapse
actually no
remember the sun is big the outer layers
wouldn't have a chance to notice the
core is collapsing
they're just too far away but the
radiation zone that surrounds the core
does notice and the inner part of it
collapses with the core
that radiation zone is still made of
hydrogen so when it collapses with the
core
it almost immediately goes critical and
starts to fuse
this forms a shell of fusing hydrogen
around the inert helium core
the light emitted from that fusion
pushes the outer layers away
while the helium core continues to
collapse underneath it
the outer layers will swell at an
accelerated pace
it'll take about a billion years or so
but it'll eventually reach venus's orbit
give or take so the earth survives
not so fast that inert helium core
is still collapsing and it won't stay
inert forever
remember things heat up as they collapse
the core
gradually goes from about 20 million
kelvin
up to a hundred million kelvin when the
sun reaches venus's orbit
that inert core reaches the critical
hundred million kelvin required for
helium fusion
it won't be inert anymore so the earth
is destroyed then
well not quite from outside the sun
the moment healing infusion begins would
look something like
this it's kind of disappointing it does
happen
suddenly which is why we call it a
helium flash
but whatever civilization is still
around probably wouldn't see anything
nothing actually flashes outside the
star
deep inside the sun though the core will
get a new lease on life
the immense amount of light being
emitted allows the core to expand again
this actually slows fusion down and
lowers the pressure on the outer layers
the sun collapses again so the earth
survives then
not so fast the core now has three
layers
a hydrogen fusing shell a helium fusing
shell
and an inert inner core made of carbon
and oxygen
just like always it attempts to find
hydrostatic equilibrium
to find balance as helium is turned into
carbon and oxygen
the core gradually collapses and heats
up again
the outer layers gradually swell again
this time
it only takes about a hundred million
years but the edge of the sun
will reach earth's orbit so the earth is
destroyed then
well maybe oh reality is complicated and
nuanced okay
during all this expanding and
contracting the sun
is going to have a hard time holding on
to its outer layers
some of those outer layers are lost to
space ultimately forming a nebula that
looks something like this
this will give earth a fighting chance
by losing some of those outer layers
the sun will be lowering its own mass
that means its hole on the planets will
weaken
the earth's orbit will grow during that
billion years or so
the problem is we don't actually know
how much it'll grow
at least not to the precision we need
but here's what we do know
the sun is massive enough and hot enough
to destroy us
in a billion years it'll get even hotter
boiling away the oceans
and turning the earth into a desert
wasteland
a few billion years after that it'll
swell into a red giant
the size of earth's current orbit it's
possible that orbit can grow
just enough for the earth to narrowly
escape destruction
at which point it'll wait for the final
breath of fusion
when the sun becomes a white dwarf the
earth will freeze into a barren rock
orbiting that white dwarf watching it
fade to black
if the earth's orbit can't grow enough
it'll be inside the outer layers of the
sun
which aren't actually that hot the earth
will continue to orbit
inside the sun for a while the
atmosphere will disappear
quickly but it'll take a really long
time for the crust to melt
and even longer for the earth to
vaporize but it will vaporize
by the time the sun becomes a white
dwarf the earth will be long gone
so what do you think will the earth be
destroyed or not
please share in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to patreon
patrons like charles complete
who help keep the show going don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy
this episode was sponsored by
squarespace the all-in-one platform to
build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
making and maintaining a website can be
overwhelming
you need good design skills coding
knowledge security concerns
squarespace handles all of that for you
they have tons of design templates that
keep your website looking professional
on all devices it's super easy no coding
necessary
i especially like that you can put in a
picture like a logo
and it will automatically build a color
palette for your site
go to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch
go to squarespace.com science asylum and
add code science asylum at checkout
to save 10 off your first purchase
the biggest thing i learned after
releasing the last video you all have
very strong opinions about which quantum
interpretation
is the right one i did not expect the
comments to be so divisive
holy cow anyway thanks for watching you